guys my name is grace Helbig if you did
not know now you know your life is
different now I'm trying to majority of
you know this if you do not know
recently myself and Hannah Hart and
mamrie Hart had a movie come out called
dirty 30 if you don't know that that
happened it's going on I've talked about
it like crazy on this channel and all my
social media if you haven't already
downloaded it please download it also
you can go to Target and buy the DVD of
it now which is just bumpers to me in my
brain one of my absolute favorite
characters in dirty thirty is a
character named Richard aka Raymond he's
played by a good friend of memories and
I named Adam lustick he plays a nerdy
uptight guy that works at a VHS rental
store the last one in the country and
then on the weekends he goes off on the
weekends I go golf I'm sorry on the
weekends I go gone gone gone Scott I go
golf people still go golf oh yeah
really oh wow didn't recognize me in my
weekend look did you so I thought fall
was coming up women's makeup in the fall
tensing of a bit darker also halloween
is coming up and so I wanted to do a
goth makeup tutorial for you guys
inspired by Raven from dirty thirty I've
never been gone in my life ever
what's this goth mean a member of a
Germanic people that invaded the Roman
Empire from the east between the third
and fifth century a style of rock music
derived from Punk typically with
apocalyptic or mystical lyrics pink what
we are referring to is the latter I have
some makeup on my face from should it
turn that this way oh well sorry I have
some makeup on my face from earlier
today so we're going to start somewhat
clean slated I'm gonna try and get as
close to Ravens look as possible so goth
luck especially in Ravens case is a very
pale skin with very very dark features
so we're going to use the lightest
foundation that I have let's try this I
have this foundation stick that's pretty
light feel free to be very heavy-handed
with this kind of look because subtlety
is not a goth look special
I'm gonna blend this all in I have this
very light concealer that I'm gonna go
under my eyes with and also over some of
the other areas oh yeah there we go I
know technically Raven works at a video
rental store but like he should really
be a firefighter cuz that guy knows how
to handle smoke yeah smokey eyes it's
very heavy heavy smoke I don't think
this was recording at all before that
what what the sorry I thought I was
recording and I wasn't basically I'm
using this two-faced smokey eye palette
that I have but feel free to use any
drugstore brand of eyeshadow that you
want I'm using the color smolder smolder
and Scully x-files
this is paranormal activity I'm doing a
makeup tutorial feel free to use an eye
primer if you want I didn't but I should
have because you want to make sure that
this look lasts so we're basically just
filling in our entire eyelid with a
black eye shadow straight up to the
eyebrow out and then we're gonna go a
little bit underneath the eye and the
fun thing about this look is that if you
haven't been sleeping and you have bags
under your eyes this is a great
camouflage there she is
so let's just match that on the other
eye kind of him beautiful so now what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take some
black eyeliner and I'm gonna line my
eyes I'm using some urban decay eye
liner called perversion we're all just a
bunch of pervs I'm gonna line my
waterline and my top lashes oh there it
is oh yeah and this is you know an
optional step you can get away with just
the eyeshadow oh there we go now the
thing about Ravens eye shadow is that it
kind of feathers out on the edges either
out these edges so they're not so harsh
yeah there it is okay now the other main
facial feature to accentuate is your
lips and guess what color we're going
with dark black dark black dark black
you can probably use this black eyeliner
on your lips if you want to I'm gonna
try something else first
I had this lipstick forever it is Kat
Von D's layered what we're going to
outline my lips in the black eyeliner
first and I love
all over the place I don't look like an
idiot there it is that feels great
now we're gonna fill it in with slayer
ah maybe I've just been in a cocoon for
years and this is my butterfly moment so
the makeup phase of our goth
transformation is done now the biggest
thing about the goth look
other than the dramatic makeup are the
accessories and Raven is on [ __ ]
trend this choker are you kidding me we
shot this movie before Coachella so like
you're welcome world for starting the
choker trend I unfortunately don't have
a choker like that but I thought I could
see iy something I have these knee-high
socks that I got at Target for $2 and I
haven't worn them so I'm going to make
them into a choker and I have a variety
of metallic beads and accessories of the
sort I'm gonna use to adorn my choker to
kind of match what Ravens got going on I
think I'm just gonna cut a long piece
and if you have a black choker already
looking grand ole situations Oh perfect
so I got my black stretchy piece of
choker and now I'm gonna take my hot
glue gun and start gluing things on it
to make it look more like rabies so I
have these gold pieces that I'm going to
apply you can use silver or gold but I
just happen to already have these gold
pieces so I'm gonna use these haha and
actually on Ravens delicate choker he
has a skull hanging down I don't have a
skull so I found these bells hot glue
one right on the middle found those gold
metal wire from a previous DIY so I'm
just gonna oh god it worked okay great
now to hot glue this on let that dry and
our look will be complete
Dada and with one quick change I have
officially become Raven what guys think
this is a great look for school weddings
for birthday party mitzvahs op mitzvahs
I hope you guys enjoyed this look let me
know if any of you plan to dress up like
any of the characters from dirty 34 this
Halloween if you do please tweet us
photos of your Halloween costumes we
would be so honored and thank you guys
for watching if you enjoyed this
give a thumbs up and subscribe to this
YouTube channel right there because I'm
all about su caving don't rip download
30 30 you haven't already link is in the
description below I don't know it smells
good and right I did not ever go cough
is this mighty necessary